For him. For God sakes. Now everyone want
to see him. Verse Earl Spence, but Earl,
his fight, Nike Garcia. Brendan,
if he was the king or the
president of MMA, how would he,
what would he do about
the steroids situation?
And he said he would get rid of Usada.
Correct.
And then have the commission seeing
her have the commission test,
which basically means that all
you gotta do is just be, you know,
it's a stupid example. You're still
going to do shit, but none of the fight.
You're clean night of the fight. What
have you cleaned them out of the fight?
Well when did that pay a clean from
a piss test. Oh, okay. I think,
I think is that how they used to do it?
Well, how they did it when I fought.
What else are fought? Brock? He was
clean. You know he tested clean. Yeah.
Cause it was a very simple urine test.
It was like quest labs type shit.
You got a job at ups and I
check with you from mushrooms.
So you the commission.
But that's how Bellah toward does it. They
just don't really, let me ask you this.
Did anybody ever approached you and
said, hey man, I think we can, uh,
we can get you on some stuff. Oh yeah. Oh
yeah, for sure. How do they say it? Uh,
it was like locker room talk like a,
they're like, Yo, I got this guy, dude,
he's great. He does this, this, this.
I can afford it. That's how it starts.
The fighters. Yeah. Or a coach would, we'd
be like, hey man, you know, can do this.
This, I couldn't afford it though. How
much are we talking? Uh, I don't know.
Cause they were going through
like a doctor and I just remember,
Dr, I don't think he's
still in business. And, uh,
I remember that your insurance won't
coach. You got paid cash or MIRA ass.
And I met Tom. I was like, Oh
fuck, that's a car payment, man.
There's no way I couldn't do it. Oh,
what I've done it probably, yeah.
Probably short window,
man.
Bob Sapp is up to lately.